you know 2020 being you know
all that it is and the movie release
schedule we've had or lack thereof
i haven't had a lot of opportunities in
the movie theater to be disappointed so
now we have this it kind of feels a
little more
normal now
[Music]
the new mutants so the new means was an
anticipated new movie coming up back in
was it supposed to come out in 2017 then
delayed till 2018. i know it's supposed
to come out in 2018
but then delayed and then delayed and
now we're here and it finally came out
and if i'm assessing
i think there's a reason there's a
strategy that they release this movie
when there's not a lot of theaters open
across the country so they can be like
all right
it came out now we don't have to think
about it obviously tenants coming out
around the same time but there's a
different thing going on there i'm
saying for new mutants
i really think that's why new means
basically revolves around this girl who
she has a new power so now she's in this
hospital this hospital because they call
it a hospital
which if you've seen the trailer and you
take one look at this place you're like
this is not a hospital i don't know what
it is is it the lack of
staff the fact that there are about five
people in this hospital
so that's basically the gist and the
premise is interesting i've always
thought
that taking the concept of x-men or a
world of mutants
and giving them powers that are very
nightmare fueled like this
merging of comic book movie and horror
movie i just found that fascinating but
there's a difference between the concept
and the execution the potential and the
reality the reality is when i was
watching this movie i was just
for the first half i was just bored i
mean it was
obvious that they understood at least
they had to get people on the side of
the characters you know all right let's
let's concentrate on the characters
that's fair the only thing is your
characters are cliche if not boring they
just check the boxes you know you have
the [ __ ] you have the [ __ ] you have
the nice guy you have the nice girl and
you have our lead who is a nice girl
but then her power is very damaging to
other people right when i
saw the [ __ ] i was like this
i half expected him you might as well
just had him chewing gum hey guys what's
up
i'm hardcore and i burn people guess
who's the alpha in the room
point to the alpha it's okay i'll give
you a minute
but it all goes down exactly how you
know it's going to go down
except the fact that you kind of assumed
that this movie will
be a bit frightening the characters are
cliche they're not that interesting not
that they're
complete [ __ ] it's just they there's
nothing beyond surface level it's like
they were like okay for the characters
we have to have the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
the nice girl the nice guy and the main
girl okay
so what do we do with the personality
someone was like
well just go to the grab bag of powers
over there and allocate powers and
i think what you listed works for the
characters i don't think we have to go
any further than that it's like they
wanted to have a comic book movie and a
horror movie and it's 50
of either which means it's the master of
neither all they ended up doing is
putting one foot in each pool
but they never committed of all the
movies going through the characters i
didn't really find that interesting
finally it's like it starts going down
to where the
scary scary things start happening it's
not even that
creepy or it's just bad cgi i mean the
girl's power i do feel like this is
spoilerish but
you sniff it out really early you're
like i'm pretty sure this is her power
her power is that she
brings out people's fears and their
fears manifest right in front of them
and they
have to live it sound familiar yes
because we saw that in a movie that
actually
did do horror well granted that
character might have existed before
it was even written i don't know they're
digging some pretty obscure characters
in this one i didn't know lockheed
lockheed was my favorite part
of all the characters in this movie the
one i knew was lockheed i was like
that's cool for the last act and the
last throwdown i actually i was
entertained by it maybe it was just
because i was glad
it finally got there like i was glad
something happened i don't know but just
all i can say is this movie
felt shoddy it felt choppy it felt like
the kind of movie that went through a
couple of studios and was delightful
this is the end product it usually
doesn't work out that well for a movie
in that situation the movie does not
serve well the concept
because the concept is amazing and every
bit of intrigue in the movie is just
kind of like a
oh yeah i know everyone else in the
theater knows too it's like ooh what's
her power you already know
long before they reveal it who's behind
all this
you know you knew from the trailer you
know exactly what company's behind all
this and it wouldn't bother me except
the fact that it's executed like oh
here's the answer and it's just like oh
no [ __ ] and i probably would have done
better to come out closer to logan you
know still riding that logan wave
it tried to but now here we are it's
kind of past its prime
i actually bagged on this movie harder
than i meant to it's not the worst ass
i've ever seen it's just
it's just not memorable and that is to
say i'm not gonna remember this one in
t-minus one
day yep already forgot i did like
lockheed though all right so the new
mutants have you been looking forward to
it are you gonna see it are you gonna
see it in the sense that yes i finally
get to see it or you just
kind of do you want to just get the car
in the parking lot at this point
what kind of metaphor that was but you
know just want you want to get there
finally or you're just going to save
your money for tenant whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you